- L'affidavit tant atten..
38 pages, dont la moitié
caviardée pour expliquer
pourquoi la résidence
de l'ancien président
a été perquisitionnée
le 8 août dernr.r.
D'emblée, on parle d'enquête
criminelle déclenchée
le 9 février après que l'équipe
de Donald Trump ait rendu
15 boîtes de documents
aux archives nationales.
Dans ces boîtes, 184 documents
uniques, dont 25 top secrets,
avec l'identité des agents
de rensenenement qui travaillent
pour le gouvernement américain.
"Il y a des informations
dans ces boîtes qui viennent
s sources humaines,
c'est-à-dire d'espions, dit-il.
S'ils sont identifiés
dadans des pays comme la Russie
ou dans d'autres dictatures,
ils sont emprisonnés
et souvent exécutés.
Ce genre d'information
est sensible. En tant qu'ancien
agent de la CIA, çmeme fait
froid dans le dos de voir
que cette information
traîne dans un sous-sol
à Mar-a-Lago."
"Les pages ntnt caviardées
pour protéger l'identité
de témoins ou d'agent du FBI",
dit le ministère de la Justice.
(coups de klaxon)
La perquisition du 8 août
est justifiée dans l'affidavit,
car selon les enquêteurs,
d'autres documents contenant
des informations sur la défense
nationale étaient toujours
à Mar-a-Lago dansnene pièce
non sécurisée.
"Quelle que soit la personne
qui possède ces documents,
dit cet avocat, si c'était
un de mes clients, il aurait été
arrêtét t emprisonné."
Donald Trump fustige
le document, parle de subterfuge
total de relations publiques
par le FBI, alors que selon lui,
son équipe a collaboré avec
le ministère de la Justice.
Et puis, il y a la lettre
de l'avocat de Donald Trump
adressée au chef du cont--
espionnage. Dans cette lettre,
l'avocat écrit que Donald Trump
avait déclassifié to
les documents, qu'il était
dans son droit et qu'il
ne devrait pas frere face
à des sanctions criminelles.
Donald Trump fait face
à d'autres enquêtes,
dont celle d'avoir tenté
de renverser les